[Music]
well of course everyone talking today
about President Obama's announcement
yesterday that he supports gay marriage
this is a historic stance that the
president's taking now personally I've
always been very broad-minded on this
issue I have three openly gay staffers
who I've had the pleasure of working
with for a long time and well I know
Obama's announcement means a lot to them
and well here they are right now Scott
chronic praise from Ed and Jeffrey
wander and congratulations guys on this
big milestone you know I believe it's
high time that gay and lesbian couples
received all the rights and privileges
enjoyed by straight couples now this
isn't a religious or moral issue but a
fairness issue that has civil social and
legal ramifications across the entire
span of a person's life from adoption
any child right can you believe Conan
brought us out here to prove how gay
friendly he is what does he know about
the struggle for gay rights the only
people who ever had a cone for his
sexual orientation or the women he dated
exactly Cohen's idea of a same-sex
relationship is him in a three-sided
mirror
way to go out on a limb Conan declaring
your pro-gay in Hollywood California I
can't wait to hear your pro-marijuana
speech at the Phish concert
Conan's sexual preference is not having
any he's afraid of rows back out his
poor wife it must be like wrestling of
stork the hardest news that Conan ever
had to break to his parents was that
he's really their son maybe Conan is
secretly gay no way there's not a gay
man alive who spends that much time on
his hair hey guys do you think straight
people know we can talk telepathically
that's why we always win the Oscar pool
[Applause]
the speech I did
you